one of the stars of that team is the
head coach at Arizona State Bobby Hurley
good morning coach how are you morning
dad how are you I'm doing okay did you
watch the rear of duke and kentucky this
past weekend I did what did you notice
that you didn't notice before having
played in that game just a greater
appreciation for I think all the shot
making especially late in the game all
the big plays in this day and age with
the game of basketball and even how much
I like my guys to go off the dribble
guys like Remy Martin Alonzo heard I
coach that have a tremendous ability to
create offense off the dribble just the
all the passing in the game those the
ball movement was pretty incredible and
then it reminded me that I was pretty
good in the old sport so it felt good
but I threw too many bad passes you know
ice and ice and waffle turnovers in
arcade - well you hit a big shot
I think the second biggest shot in that
game obviously Laettner shot to win it
but you miss a three rebound back to you
top of the key
nail the three I thought that was the
second biggest shot by a Duke in that
game how did you feel like that was a
big big moment there you know the timing
of it was certainly but I was yeah I was
empowered euro by Coach K he just always
gave us a lot of freedom he trusted us
you know he instilled confidence so even
after our best there was no hesitation I
had I had made a few big shots in my
career so it was it was something that
you know I felt like you know it was my
time to contribute and I think that was
the beauty of the team we had so many
guys that could make plays that would
step up you know and in big moments and
even coach k thought hey if we get a
long offensive rebound
let's look out to the three-point line
because we got guys that could make
shots were you disappointed at all
leaving the huddle that you weren't
going to be part of that final play
where grant throws the ball to Christian
look I sat with my family with my wife
Leslie and my daughters my son and we
really never watched that game together
and you know I was so mad at myself for
missing my pull-up jump shots and
regulation and but it did help make the
make that game even more special and so
that's how I look at it so I had my
chance and I didn't catch her and so
someone else's turn yeah but nobody
guarded Grant Hill on the baseline
like I'm still yelling out nobody like
the game of course is you know decades
old I'm going nobody's guarding Grant
Hill nobody no-nobody fronted Laettner
and nobody guarded grant yeah I think
some of it is a feel thing and even I do
there's a codes I don't have a set
guidelines for how to handle that
situation I think it it's more on the
personnel and you know but but it's it's
tough when you have a guy that's made
every shot in the game and he's made you
know all those free throws and your
first instinct as a coach that's what I
don't fault like Rick Pitino's like
don't foul him because the likelihood of
getting a high percentage shot with that
amount of time is very low so you can
understand why that maybe they didn't do
a better job of nonlin christian touches
yeah I was just curious that if as a
coach would you have if you had one
option yet that you had to pick you
either front Christian or you could
guard the base line with Grant Hills
throw what would you I'm I mean I'm most
likely in a situation what it would have
a guy on the basketball that my best
jumper got the most length to try and
even make it a worse pass and a less
accurate pass with that amount of time
but again that's that's up to to every
individual I've been burned that way as
a coach back at Buffalo in a very
similar situation you know my best
player went for a steal at the opposite
of a line and didn't get it and the
player from the Ohio University you went
in and dunked it at the buzzer so I've
had both ends of it we're talking to
Bobby Hurley Arizona State head
basketball coach and they would have
gone to the NCAA tournament that would
have been for the third straight year
Arizona State had not done that since
the early sixties so about 55 years
weren't you the most outstanding player
of that final four that we
talking about yeah Dan I had broke my
foot like in the middle of that season
so I missed like three weeks and I was
just starting to get back to where I was
prior to the injury and after Christian
going ten for ten to the field temper
temper in line in 30 you know Bobby
Knight was a pretty good code so he
wasn't gonna let Christian beat him in
that national semi-final I thought I had
you know my best game of the season
against Indiana and I Final Four and
then you know we went on and you know
Grant was outstanding Grant Hill and me
in the Michigan game Thomas Hill and
Tony Lange so we got like you know a lot
of our other guys or you know that's why
were such a good team really stepped up
and that final four to help you know
what Christian wasn't at his best
it was Laettner upset that you got the
most outstanding player I don't think so
he had enough Awards Dan I'm pretty sure
you see he's pretty competitive some
place is pretty pretty filled he's he's
pretty competitive no Bobby yeah but he
was a winner I mean he just wanted to
win man he just really it wasn't for him
about the numbers and accolades I mean
I'm sure he appreciated that stomping
but but it was it was more about winning
I I'm fat still fascinated when I watch
I hate Christian Laettner
I think a guy every year it just feels
like you know hey March Madness is
starting Wednesday I hate Christian
Laettner document 34:30 coming on what
did you think of it yeah well yeah I
mean Christian was was very polarizing
and you know especially opposing crowds
you would be a magnet for you know their
venom and so it was I think he enjoyed
that role so to a large degree he talked
about the feeling of sending everyone
home that just yelled at him for about
two hours
he enjoyed those last few minutes of
those situations when's the last time
you talked to Coach gay a while back
your we kind of via text more than
anything you know during the season were
both super busy you know with everything
and so yeah it's it's it's been a while
on the phone but yeah certainly we keep
up with some tax what
you do since you can't get out of the
house as a coach well I mean it was
tough that that last day and so much was
unknown about the virus the impact that
it's having so it's completely
understandable understandable why the
pac-12 tournament was canceled the day
we were supposed to play we were there
in Vegas ready to play and just being
having to go into that room and tell our
team that the season's over and all they
worked for it was going to be no NCAA
tournament and you know like you touched
on it would been the first time since
1960 guy like Remy Martin is one of the
best players in the packs well you know
didn't get a chance to to play in the
taxol tournament or the NCAA tournament
you have our seniors you know Robin
where it's Mickey Mitchell that you know
their careers were over and so it was a
tough day and and then you just move on
it's you know you stay in touch with the
guys make sure they're well like we you
know we have a meeting today with all
the parents on the phone on on a
conference call just to make sure they
they have all the information that we
could provide for them as we go through
this you know difficult time for the
country so trying to take care of
ourselves take care of our players and
you know and focus on you know getting
through this you got a basketball hoop
at the house I don't there's a little
park down down the way the you know my
son has been going to I haven't been
able to even you know get myself build
myself up to go to a court but we plan
on getting out a little to the outdoor
Court again my son and I this week
when's the last time you played a pickup
game I played in at the Final Four last
year was it was it it was like a
celebrity game and I think my coach was
Shaq Shaq was my coach and magic was the
other coat so it was pretty cool you
know I didn't do very much I just tried
to keep the real basic I just my game is
it's deteriorating by the moment who did
you pattern your game after I mean I
loved Isiah Thomas I thought I could not
I tried to use my imagination a dribble
of the basketball and you know in my
neighborhood I I'd be dribbling too
park every day and my neighbors talked
about they were so happy when what I
want to do presented enough to hear you
know the ball bouncing up and down the
street all the time so I really got a
joy out of dribbling the ball and being
creative off the dribble yeah good stuff
well I hope you're doing okay there
sorry about the the tournament another
great year for you with 20 wins but
thanks for checking in with us Bobby
Chris hey you Dan and stay safe and
healthy everyone out there Bobby Hurley
Arizona State head basketball coach